right after those Nana okay I'm still
hearing conversation there's that then
right okay welcome to this first meeting
of the cabinet of 2018 fairly hefty
agenda but so hopefully we'll pass it
through fairly debroglie smoothly part
is for absence incarcerated right
disclosures of interest
none at all
no chairman of the Council right minutes
to confirm and sign the minutes of the
meeting held on 27th of November I have
them here they have been circulated are
you happy there a true record of events
that today it seems a long time back to
27 to November doesn't it but there we
are we've had Christmas in between right
item for will coat neighborhood
development plan this is a fairly
straightforward in fact it's wool coat
and path low neighborhood development
plan we have the document and we've seen
this through its various stages in
various iterations and the particular
issue before us today is to receive the
report of the referendum
now it had one or two problems on the
way because the boundaries of world Co
Parish were changed at one time and we
had to accommodate that so consequently
we have on page 17 paragraph 3.1 the
local community endorsed the plan with a
ninety three point eight five percent
yes vote and a handful of people voting
no right so consequently we have a
situation but the option over to us only
one option is to effectively say right
let's adopt this make it as it's often
called I'm looking around for Matt Neal
he's not oh he's there surya and he and
i have discussions about the term make
but whatever we want to say we're going
to say let's put this into action as a
result of the detailed preparation work
that have been done between this council
and the neighborhood plan group and that
very very positive referendum result so
the recommendation is going to council
where it'll go on the 26th of february
which is the next time we meet so do we
have any comment on that proposal no
right so are you ready should I put the
recommendation to the cabinet and that's
agreed isn't okay thank you
the next item if I can find it one worn
neighborhood development plan slightly
less pictorial front but then they
haven't got Mary albums house in there
would warn however that's gone through
exactly the same process it's been
thoroughly assess we've had it at
cabinet for approval at its various
stages and indeed we've support it
pretty much the issues and the changes
that have taken place so consequently we
now have slightly slightly weaker
support eighty nine point seven five
percent yes vote and that left just over
ten percent saying no but we have a
situation whereby the pointers in the
right direction because we've given our
blessing to the contents of the plan
that was referendum and they've come out
with a positive results I think we have
very little opportunity other than to
endorse it to make it and therefore put
it into the bank
well except we have to ask council to do
that rather than do it ourselves any
discussion on that recommendation on
page 19 wooden wall Neighborhood
Development Plan is adopted with
immediate effect the matter game will be
as of the 26th of February hopefully the
council will effectively follow our
recommendation is that agreed great
thank you
right when some six is built up area
boundaries for local service villages
Knapton on the hill members will recall
that we looked at built-up area
boundaries recently and indeed thought
that we had dealt with everything and
then along comes naps and I said you
haven't taken
you notice of the comments that we put
forward to you which we said whoops
that's correct and as a result this
paper has been brought forward today I
understand that's the Parish Council I'm
not so enthusiastic for us to consider
it but they'll be speaking in a moment
so I will call their their chairman
along to actually address the cabinet
this afternoon we do need to resolve
this but also I need to tell people or
inform people because they should know
it that effectively these built-up area
boundaries are going into another piece
of documentation which effectively will
be out for consultation during the
spring haven't got firm dates as yet and
as such I want to as such I want to
reserve my position on exactly when that
might happen so there will be an
all-round consultation on all the
built-up area boundaries although we
hope in the main that nothing new will
come about because it is time-consuming
processing public representation much as
we are obliged to seek it and much as
I'm keen to a certain it happens it can
be time-consuming and we don't want to
do the same job twice so the proposal is
for effectively asked to choose that
outcome but before we do that
I'll ask councillor Woodcock from
adapting on the hill parish council to
come forward can you come forward to a
microphone please and then press the
button in front so the red light comes
on it's okay applause yours thank you
good afternoon
my name is Richard Woodcock I'm a parish
councillor for the village of Knutson on
the hill and I also sit on the
Neighborhood Development Planning Group
when the built-up area boundary was
first rolled out in July last year
Knapton Parish Council was consulted and
fearing a loss of green spaces within
the village
and not fully understanding the
implications decided to ask the process
to draw the boundary even tighter to
remove some of those green spaces to
outside the boundary and to take our
allotment site which had been included
within the boundary outside as you will
know that request was lost due to an
administrative error which is why this
issue is now back with you today a lot
of good work has been achieved over the
past six months and our merging
neighborhood development plan is well on
track for completion later this year we
are currently engaged in the process for
housing needs survey to determine local
requirements and what we've come to
realize in hindsight is that by asking
for a reduced built a barrier boundary
we have actually eliminated our options
and if those pros proposals were now
ratified today there would be no space
left within the amended built-up area
boundary to build suitable homes for the
future which will Copa our village alive
and vibrant in particular our allotment
site owned by the village is considered
by many to be no longer fit for purpose
being on a steep slope with no car
parking
many of the allotments have become
overgrown through disuse we are now
considering options to reciting the
allotment to a more appropriate location
within the village but outside the
built-up area boundary better suited to
our needs which could then free up the
redundant site for housing potential at
our parish council meeting last Monday
we considered reconsidered our position
and a proposal was unanimously voted
upon and passed to withdraw the request
before you today to amend the built-up
area boundary and to ask this cabinet to
choose option one appendix one proposed
built-up area boundary of the five
options on the papers before you in
other words to leave the built-up area
boundary exactly as it was previously
drafted and approved with no changes and
our green spaces and allotments
allotment site left inside the boundary
so the village has some scope to grow
and develop
to fulfill operations in the communities
best interests this then fulfills key
objective two of the core strategy and
si P consultation people in their
environment which relates amongst other
things to the delivery of housing
targets and landscape environmental
protection when considering new
developments and key objective three
responsible community leadership which
encourages amongst other things joint
working between Stratford District
Council and local communities to achieve
benefits for residents okay yes I forgot
to warn you on a time it smack on thank
you so well done okay so what we're
being told is we don't necessarily have
the choice of three options which is
what was in the prepared in the
paperwork which was prepared when we
discovered that effectively we hadn't
taken accountable options or didn't
necessarily reflect the parish's view
we've now had the parish's view and what
mister will counsel Woodcock is saying
is can we please pick option one
appendix one give them some chance to
build although I have to admit that it
is possible to put in a planning
application outside the built-up area
boundary and it's possible to approve
that under the right circumstances
however but I understand what you mean
is you're saying this is part of the
village this open space and therefore
any development that might occur is
something we will prefer to happen there
it is what you're saying right any
comments for members
happy happy right so therefore what we
want is the recommendation again to
counsel because they've they approved it
and they will be or someone will be
approving the consultation based on
these decisions so what we say is that
we actually don't change the decision
the council has already been made and
that the draft be oh you will be habeas
at an appendix one be received in the
doors as appropriate to be including
within the draft si P it's the draft si
P that will effectively be out for
consultation shortly have we got an
approximate date for that John no you
were allowed to say now if we haven't oh
I see right oh it's a minute okay later
this month
counselor riches thanks Jeff um does
this have to go back to counsel because
if it's already been done and this is to
form the draft for the sak which we know
is going to have an extensive
consultation and come back to Council
can we not just do it here given that
the status quo remains well you ain't
gonna go back to council with all the
things published further is it
I'm gonna look to mr. drafted on this
one we're not changing the previous
decision of the council
a paper has been published which gave a
scope to do that and based on the
requests of the parish council we're not
doing it yes they gave me what we've
already decided so the recommendation on
the paper
page 19 is the recommendations council
what I'm saying is can we just then
maintain the status quo by so basically
we got no further recommendation that
way I don't know whether it just scrap
it only a mr. Grafton gave us an opinion
please I think I'm going to have to draw
in mr. kefir to establish what was sent
through to Council when this was last
discussed at cabinet whether it included
appendix the appendix one version of the
Knapton on the hill and I'm getting a
nod so so in effect the decision has
already been I think actually isn't that
wasn't there an amendment to include
some garish space or something there's
no meant for garages we're just asking
it to stay exactly as it is yes I think
the question that mr. Grafton is asking
you John is are we amending councils
previous decision
Thank You chair if if members are minded
to go with appendix one there will be no
change to the previous decision yeah
there were three changes proposed to
shown in pending cases two three
but pendeks one is no change we're being
asked to follow the pendeks one aren't
we in that case there is no decision to
be made at today's cabinet right okay so
we note the position but we've got a
record something in the minutes because
we've debated it so we note the position
of the Parish Council and recommend no
change to the approved build-up area
boundary would that be satisfactory mr.
Antin that's fine okay right well I own
this agree first is that agree right
thank you thank you
right item seven notice of motion
housing mix this is a sensitive subject
and I'll open the matter up for
discussion but I'm mindful to recommend
that we actually get an officer report
on this there are some figures floating
around at the present time which have
been collated by officers as to how we
may all varied from the core strategy
requirement and then if we're going to
tackle whether or how we handle that I
think we need some professional advice
on the way
councillor moss thank you chairman Jaron
yes indeed a study of recent
applications I think reveals to
everybody that almost every large site
is coming forward as an exception to the
rules on housing mix and the the core
strategy is quite clear and was ever
space will accepted by the inspector
with good reasons as to why the laid
down housing mix should be followed it
also did allow exceptions to be made to
take into account site circumstances
circumstances but everybody seems to be
wanting to be treated as no exception
and Chairman no surprise everybody is
coming forward with reduced numbers of
small families and increased percentages
of large houses
so what we're requesting here is that
the cabinet look at whether there should
be some policy the controllers because
otherwise I do believe that the holy mix
lay there in the core strategy is in
danger frankly have become a completely
meaningless Sherman I'm not sure whether
it needs policies to control this or
whether we need guidelines that can be
done more quickly what I would say is
there is degree of urgency about these
because applications are coming forward
all the time to planning committees are
getting approved and if we're not
careful if the policy takes too long to
get into place it will be too late and
the horse will be bolted then we close
in the stable door afterwards so quite
happy to take advice from officers as to
whether it's a policy or guidelines you
need but I do believe we need something
fairly urgently Thank You councillor
Pemberton Thank You leader Thank You
councillor Morse I think that it would
be fair to say that everyone shares
concerns around situations where
prospective developers are seeking to
move away from the core strategy
policies around has a mix and indeed
around affordable housing when issues of
viability raised and certainly I start
from the standpoint that it isn't
difficult to make money building houses
in this district so we all should need
some serious persuading to move away
there's already this is already
something we're certainly at least on
the viability for
there's already some we're looking at
that and I think running alongside that
has it makes I think it's something that
cuts across policy do we need to revisit
policy not sure we need to revisit
policy because when the policy is fairly
straightforward it has been tested by
the inspector and it's more about
finding the tools that we can deploy to
support the policies we have in the core
strategy and I think it's not you know
it is something that has members across
this councils attention because it's it
is something that affects all members so
there's really something for us too that
we should you know I think you know
which we should be looking at this is is
to to look at a report that enables us
to understand what are the various
levers we can pull not sure it's
necessarily guidelines I think certainly
development officers and planned policy
officers are clear about the policy
standpoint it's about in the wider
context where the government has
particularly you know tests around
viability you know what are the tools we
can bring to bear so I think yeah
bringing forward a piece of work he's
not unreasonable in that sense and
certainly there's it will it would
follow on from other pieces of work that
we're trying to do at the moment council
Rich's so I'm sympathetic to this motion
because I agree I think it's happening
more and more often where the smaller
houses are being removed and replaced
with a four bedroom and so on and I
think there's two ways that we can go
here first of all should we have a
policy that deals with this well I think
we probably already have CS 19 in the
core strategy which forms our planning
policy so should the portfolio holder
look at how we are more robustly or how
we're enforcing CS 19 now out of today's
meeting or do we have another reports
come back to perhaps strengthen C as 19
in the way that it's actually executed
those are the two choices I think
I'd actually say it's actually it
potentially could be both I think we I
think we were all comfortable that our
policy stance has been tested by the
inspector and it's a starting point it
may be that when we look at what levers
we are we are available to us that there
may be some work I'm just conscious not
to start rewriting policy and the core
strategy particularly is I'm not the
portfolio holder for that and I do think
this is definitely something that cuts
across that my portfolio on the leaders
portfolio whole poly portfolio around
policy but I think he's more about in
terms of a report it's more it says of
an action plan and I think actually I'm
probably thinking in terms of an action
plan and a report that says this is the
action plan that's been put in place
rather than can we agree in action plan
I think because of the urgency involved
this is about understanding what our
officers can do and then updating the
cabinet and wider members around that
right I tend to agree with current
speakers
I am the portfolio holder for policy and
the policy was adopted by this council
in July 2016 which is simply 18 months
ago and as councilor Pemberton has just
pointed out the evidence base that gave
rise to that policy was signed off by a
plan inspector and it's all part and
parcel of what made our plan sound so we
don't want the plan to be undermined I
don't think we can solve it today so I
think we start off with a principle that
probably policy is not the thing to
change we have to look at it from a
development point of view and indeed I
think that's what councilor Rich's was
probably suggesting but we do have some
guidelines here policy can produce those
it's doing we've got an example of it
coming up later in its agenda in that it
can promote supplementary planning
guidance but I'm not quite sure the best
way to handle it which is why I'm
suggesting originally in my introduction
that we do go for a report
I admit that takes time and councillor
Morse has suggested that there are
dangers in dilly-dallying on this but
planning committees of course do have
two choices when they get a planning
application they can either approve it
or they can dismiss it so consequently
but I think the there are two things
that can happen now if we have a report
on how to deal with it I'm sure that
Darren and I could work together to
actually produce this there's no
difficulty there we'll make certain he's
available sometimes but but in general
terms once he is we can sitting down and
sort that out that's not a problem
the big problem would be is if we just
let things drift on indiscriminately
now with the motion and with the
dialogue we're having today right they
had a service that deals with planning
applications is listening intently to
what we're saying so he will have a
clear idea that he can cascade down to
his own staff as to what the mood of
members of this council is and it's not
to necessarily modify quite so many
applications what tends to happen is
because of the way that these
developments have been approved a lot of
them were approved in the run-up to the
core strategy adopting therefore they
are outline planning applications and I
think some of these deviations from the
policy are coming through a reserved
matters stages rather than a request to
modify an approved decision but whatever
the case we need to make certain we keep
it under control because we do need
smaller houses and for people to buy and
get on the starting ladder and also to
deal with the other people we need
smaller houses on the affordable section
as well I know this is not
we covered by the motion because
otherwise how the hell are we going to
actually house everybody that's on the
housing waiting lists at the present
time well what people might argue we're
never gonna house everybody but we want
to have a go at housing those whose
needs are effectively more critical than
others so I'm going to propose that we
pick option two I think it is B to defer
consideration of the motion to avoid
reports from the officers of the next
available museum cabinet so I'll propose
that from the chair councillor Moss you
object into that oh yeah no chairman I
just want to point out that I've got
applications affordable mix has been
very good I asked because it's quite
clear from what you said there is
widespread support for the idea of
greater enforcement of the housing mix
it's late then the core strategy so that
the planning officers take note of the
concern from this meeting and take it
into account when making recommendations
coming forward to planning our IDs
before the decision on any policy or
changes is finally made because as was
explained to you at the scrutiny
committee last week quite a Blee by mr.
Grafton and we categorized the
decision-making process of the council
with a structure that we've got we as a
cabinet can only deal with the executive
matters I don't think we can use
executive matters to direct what happens
in a regulatory process mr. Grafton is
agreeing with my in that statement
therefore I said a moment ago if you
remember councillor Morse but no doubt
that mr. weeks is listening intently to
conversations and we'll make a note
which he can cascade there I think we've
got to leave it at that at the present
time that he picks up messages from
members and acts accordingly or advises
the case officers to acts accordingly
clearly there are some where a change
might be justified and as some where
it's not
being we've couldn't change the balance
of that in the first instance
whilst we get the appropriate
documentation in place to give him some
guidance
I'm sure he is I don't think we need to
ask him right I put a proposal forwards
them to defer to get oh that's all right
a second did them thought you were gonna
prolong the debate then write that
proposal is that agreed agreed
great thank you right item 8 WCC
Children's Center proposed by forchick
seconded by Barnes well what Jake isn't
here but Barnes has put his hand up so
would you like to come forward Peter i
seconded this motion for the simple
reason there's they're both my
daughter-in-laws our teachers have
children that are have a problem of
school that most of the problems appear
to be before they get to school these
sort of centers are a major aspect of
them when I was chairman of the County
Council I opened one in Nuneaton woman
came in with a baby sort of 12 weeks old
left it there and said I'll be back when
I've gone shopping I think a lot of
children now unfortunately not you mean
in rural areas whether I have to take
not this dog but another dog to our
schools to Kuantan children again does a
wonderful job
Ulster schools have a dog degree which
kids can take home and I think a lot of
the problem is basically they don't get
they like before they get to school but
they should do and these centers do
health I don't know whether we can do
any of them
but armed only too happy to have
seconded the motion although
disappointing that different version
isn't there although I did speak to him
the other day but I live it in your
capable hands but I do feel that some
children aren't getting the good chance
it was fired where they went to school
it's now for better chance but both my
daughter-in-laws have to work with
children who did need or their parents
needed at the time when I was chairman
of the County Council the Health
Authority district nurses were cutting
down and that's why the County Council
took be done I leave it in your capable
hands and will support whatever you want
to do all right thank you Peter I'm not
totally happy with the elements of this
even though we're capable hands it first
of all says that the leader has already
said he opposes the proposals of WCC I
didn't exactly say that I invited the
leader of the County Council did we draw
them and replace them with something
very different I've since had a meeting
with her and she's assured me and
several of my colleagues or our
colleagues that effectively the
proposals that she's bringing forward
weren't fully articulated in the
cost-saving proposals that were voted on
and indeed they are evolving so I think
my judgment on whether I'm supportive or
opposed to them is it's probably
something that needs to be taken into
account and could evolve over a period
of time
I certainly object it to having one
Children's Center in Stratford District
and that one was in Ulster that was a
balmy suggestion but however they opened
the one that's below however they have
changed that and as I said I've had an
assurance from the lead
the Cancer Council the services are
involving and I think because of the
reactions of this council and the local
press to their original proposals I
genuinely think that she will probably
have a dialogue with us as proposals
develop the second objection I have is
you're asking us to put our reserves
into funding a gap I think that's
fraught with difficulties because we
can't quantify the size of that gap at
the present time and nor do we know if
we were to do that without our money
would be wisely spent or whether we'd
have any control over it
we haven't been requested to support
funding there are facilities within
legislation for one council to take on
the role of something else but you're
not suggesting that you're saying we've
got loads of reserves let's sub them now
that's not practical because as well we
evolved as will be revealed later our
reserves are running at a higher level
than we are proposing for the long-term
but they're cushioning the blow you'll
remember many years ago councillor
Barnes because you were here with me
when the district element of council tax
went up by quite a large amount simply
because the previous administration that
you supported did not raise council tax
would it be prudent to have done so they
used as Sonny's familiarities pom they
used all the money from the head well
whatever the case the situation is if we
start running down our reserves now we
will effectively make budget setting in
the next three or four years somewhat
difficult because my learning colleague
mr. Buckland what I'm talking my
learning colleague mr. Buckland has said
quite emphatically that you know we have
a he's articulated
remember decisions but effectively that
effectively will see the level of
reserves reduce they can spend it twice
so we can't use it to buffer around
future and do the counter council's work
that's my comments anyway I'm just going
to say I did say at the start I don't
know what you can do you obviously have
looked at it and and I thank you for
talking to the County Council to maybe
move way and some way forward right
counsel Jefferson I would just endorse
what you were saying about feedback from
the leader of the County Council it is
pretty obvious that things have moved
forward quite significantly from the
initial proposals it has been said that
the model is still being developed and
will evolve over time that was actually
said very openly to us from what we were
told the service is going to be better
targeted at people who really need the
service through outreach and what was
also said was that more money and
resources will be put into outreach and
what they are talking about is a common
pattern seen across the country that has
been demonstrated to deliver better
results in short I think all the
representations that were actually made
for the County Council have resulted in
a considerable number of changes that
have made if you like an improved
potential offering the test will always
be whether that delivers on the ground
but nevertheless I think it has moved
forward very substantially from the
original proposals councilor it is
thanks Jaron as you know I'm usually
keen to get things wrapped up quickly
and make sort of strong decisions to try
and improve situations with regards to
this I don't think there's an awful lot
we can do with regards to
second-guessing what Warren County
Council are going to do with regards to
the children centers because that's a
moving feast
that's going to continue to evolve over
the coming months so if we were to pull
the trigger and I use that term
carefully if we were to pull the trigger
on this motion today I think that would
be a major decision a hasty decision
that we could put ourselves in an
awkward position
if Warwickshire County Council continued
to change the proposal so my
recommendation would be to reject the
motion I option 8 right any other
further comments
thank you very much miss Jim right the
well Rene is that we consider the
content without the benefit of any
report well we haven't decided that yet
but effectively I would like to endorse
what councillor Jefferson said because I
think there is an issue in the 48 hours
after the leader the county counts that
received my letter until when they made
a decision both at their scrutiny
committee and at their fault cabinet
those proposals changed and therefore we
did have some impact and some influence
on just where we are and where we're
going I think many people think there's
some more ground to be done but I don't
think we can consider what we can do in
the question of the Children's Centres
until they start coming out with more
proposals it's as simple as that
so councillor riches are suggested we
take option a and reject the motion any
comment I'm getting yeses around the
table so I'll put that to the meeting
then that we effectively consider option
a we consider the content without the
benefit of report from offices and we
reject the motion is that agreed thank
you right off we go this appeals
neighbourhood of development plan now
we've approved this beforehand at
various stages we agree some time ago to
the content of the report the inspector
or the examining officer has looked at
it and he came back with a number of
recommendations to change which this
council has challenged they're all
listed in here we have the report the
submission version we have the
examiner's report
April to May 2017 was it taking that
long to get here then but more
importantly in appendix one I think it
is what I can't find it I'm flicking
through the pages the assessment has
been to look at the inspectors
modification the examiners
recommendation and you'll see with the
first one on page for modification not
agreed and then on page six modification
agreed so consequently and as we go down
you'll find most of them have been
agreed one or two of them have not been
there for I've had to look at these very
carefully as portfolio holder and decide
whether or not I concur with the
challenges to the examiner's report and
I have done which is why the paper is
here before us today so consequently the
papers here for us today because it's
time to survey this off to referendum
but it needs our approval to do so
doesn't need the Council's approval it
needs our approval as the conveyor of
executive business to make certain that
we have got it right or they have got it
right and all the issues have
effectively been satisfactorily
addressed in your hands chaps do we or
do we not send it to referendum in its
current format in the recommended format
yes chairman that we send it to
referendum right well I'm getting
positive nods so shall we all do it
together
recommendations on page 39 ah that the
decision statement appendix 1b receipt
of endorse that's the document I've just
referred to and the planners as does it
modify be endorsed as meeting the basic
conditions and all other requirements
and should proceed to referendum great
thank you
right
parking standard sorry this is me again
right now the parking standards report
is a document which effectively will
form part of supplementary planning
guidance the leaders policy advisory
group that reviews these things has been
looking at this up for some time and
there are various rules that we publish
as a supplement to the core strategy
which are things that we take into
account when development control when
planning applications come in so we have
a situation whereby we have rules and
regulations about who does what and
we're basically face officers and this
is about parking and we know it's been
coming we know there's been problems
I've sat at planning committees as
though we're dealing with this we're
getting this right this it will say so
and so be told to sit down and shut up
because it's not been approved yet
however we're getting very much nearer
to approving it it will form part of a
wider document called the development
requirements SPD
and that is expected public consultation
in february/march with adoption during
the summer 2018 so consequently we've
taken this one out and brought it
forward we can't give it the full way
that it's gonna get as part of an SPD
but I think we can endorse it so there
has sufficient weight as befits a piece
of documentation that has been approved
by cabinet and therefore then reflected
in the decisions or the recommendations
of case officers and the decisions of
both them under delegated powers plus
the planning committees Council then
Thank You chairman I welcome the parking
standards reports here the draft report
and would be pleased to see that adopted
as soon as possible for use by planning
committees accepting one part of it
which is in the residential parking
standards appendix one where it seeks to
take into account availability of other
parking within the vicinity of a
development which would mean parking
standards may not necessarily have to
apply if the was are the parking
available in the vicinity which does
concern me because although at the time
that the application is looked at there
may be as a parking of in the vicinity
however that will not be under the
control of the applicant and therefore
cannot be judged to be available for the
long term duration of the actual
application so I would prefer to see
that removed from this document and that
any application should stand and fall on
its own merits of whether or not it has
sufficient parking
rather than being able to rely on spaces
which are out of its control and
therefore that can disappear Thank You
councillor Jefferson audibly totally
with water
councillor organist said it is I think
this is long overdue if one looks at
Stratford Town the number of on-street
parking spaces is limited that are
formed far more permits an issue than
there are parking spaces the problem
continues to be exhaust ability so I see
this as a way of bringing if one day I
put it this way some sanity back to the
issue I would agree wholeheartedly with
availability of parking in the vicinity
being deleted on page 49 and I would
suggest the same should be done on page
51 right I'm fairly supportive of that
modification I know this documents been
through l pag and therefore it's said I
will have endorsed it well that's true
what was I didn't pick this one up but I
know it's not just in Stratford
councillor Jefferson we have a similar
situation in Shipton where effectively
we have public car parks and we get
recommendations coming to the Planning
Committee to grant them on the grounds
that there are car parking spaces
available well I take the view that we
actually provide those car parking
spaces and I've seen mr. Beeman nodding
same will be true in steadily we have
car parking spaces there and what are
they there for they're not for residents
the day for shoppers and they're for
people at work in the town of the
village and therefore it should not be
assumed that we can effectively put
forward planning put forward
vacations or support applications we've
actually gobble up some of those spaces
because if you want to know about
parking and ships and come be a fly on
the wall in my house and seeing how his
wife gets onto the leader of the council
why not I'm going to get more than
always bloody lot parking Sansa and so
on you know problem same in Ulster is it
however so consequently but there was
also another query I've got on page 51
from sort of discussion with cabinet
members the paragraph halfway down the
page it says most new class a
developments tend to be through changes
of use as such existing on an off street
parking is available
well again the same rule applies that
we've just been talking about should
this parking be dedicated to the new
retail initiative or development or
should we resist it should we say sorry
whoever you are we haven't got room to
put a shop on air because there's
nowhere for your customers apart
I hesitate because I thought someone was
gonna join in the debates on that cow so
Jefferson I think you should delete that
sentence leader such existing on an
Austrian is available yes I think that
is potentially very dangerous assumption
members oh yeah I think I would endorse
that particularly but given that the
parking standard refers to a class
rather than the subdivision so we could
be talking about the redevelopment
public has a restaurant a takeaway that
adds you know significant additional
parking requirements I think as it's
currently worded I think I'd struggle
with that because there seems to be
proposals to delete three three pieces
of tech twine on page 49 on the very
last paragraph knock out the words
availability of parking in the vicinity
and then on page 51 in the very last
paragraph again knock out availability
of parking in the vicinity and then two
paragraphs up the one that starts most
new class a developments as such
existing on an off street parking is
available not that paragraph that
sentence out councilman yes
sorry there are two occasions on page 49
when it occurs and the second occasion
is at the end of the second paragraph
which starts the standards will be used
as guide read on read on read on impact
of Highway Safety and then delete the
remainder which is and the level of
provision that already exists on site
and in the vicinity aren't on site fine
in the vicinity not
right say what do you want to do about
that because it's talking about the
impact on the provision of exists in the
facility so he's handing the vicinity to
take out John Thank You chair and you've
heard the proposals indeed and I I said
the reason for bringing forward this
reporters officers were aware the it's a
hot topic big issue for four members the
the challenge obviously we have historic
towns in particular of how to
accommodate
modern life in the private and the
private car and it's it's getting that
balance really because L Belltown and
video centers are arguably the most
sustainable locations we have in the
district there where the shops and
services are there with public transport
as far as e it goes where those services
focus on and so you're trying to retain
the vitality of using those areas
whether it's safe flats above shops
whether it's additional retail or or
pubs or or whatever and balance that
with the fact that as a society we do
use our cart for you know to live our
lives and there's always going to be a
balance to strike up see if members are
reminded to to make those something for
changes it will make it a far
difficult or far more challenging for
new development to come forward in town
center locations the the upshot of that
is that
those other words the same relocation to
not utilize four euros best thing they
could be your pressure then goes on on
in other areas so there's no real right
or wrong answer it's about striking that
balance and offices felt that having
these parking standards but
acknowledging that there may be
circumstances when existing off street
parking may be appropriate was the right
balance to achieve and now urge members
to think very carefully about the
implications on the economic health of
district and utilization of brownfield
land and so forth by having incredibly
stringent parking standards that might
otherwise prevent otherwise the
statement from coming forward right
you've provoked a few numbers of hands
coming up Jon Cassar rich users first
thanks Jay yeah I've got some concerns
over stripping the wording out so I was
just so here thinking about examples
whereby that might cause problems so if
you look at South and tone Center which
isn't particularly vibrant we could
probably do do with more going on there
there's Wood Street car park which
belongs to the District Council which is
pretty much underutilized a lot of the
time so if somebody wanted to build a
new retail unit in the town center would
we not be permitted to look at the fact
that Wood Street provides ample parking
for that to happen and it's all about
retail here so that's on one end of the
scale for me that would give me a cause
for concern some of the some of our
towns particularly stratford-upon-avon
don't really have the room to start
building new car parks by way of
planning policies if you want to build a
new shop you've got a build car park and
another example that came to mind was if
you look at the BHS building which we
would actively be trying to get that
repopulated because it's good for the
town so if somebody wanted to redevelop
a hundun if that's feasible because of
being a listed building whatever it's an
example are we not permitted to look at
the fact that bridge for car park is 100
yards away so that will give me concern
and then on the other end of this
if you look at the male bird center if
somebody wanted to put a new unit on the
neighborhood center are we not allowed
to include the fact that there are so
many thousand car parking spaces already
there so on reflection I kind of think
that we should be able to take a broader
view on car parking spaces that are
available in the vicinity that doesn't
necessarily mean that you get the green
light to build whatever you like because
there's a car park nearby it just means
that at least officers can take a view
on that
so I kind of now feel like we should
keep the wording and so I know Jefferson
I really don't agree with councillor
Ritchie's certainly ain't er well but I
think a lot of that is covered on the
and other relevant factors yes I think
the problem actually is a form put too
much waiting on availability of parking
in the vicinity it is too easy to get
things through yes and if I look at a
particular instance in Stratford where
Fordham house was constructed 30 old car
parking spaces for 80-odd flats and they
people doing the letting now are
advising people to apply for parking
permits in Arden Street car park and you
think to yourself this isn't nonsense so
that's one of the reasons why I really
want this I would like to see this
really tighten don't cancel Jefferson
Burton he's councilor Jefferson your
counsel affirmative
I am was reinforced no no I supported
you now
and thank you I think there's two
distinct areas here the one is a
residential and the other is the
business use and I think I would and I
think the two ought to be dealt with
quite separately and I was sort of
concerned that there was a bit of a
confusion because I'm 51 it's about
non-residential parking standards and of
course Fordham house is residential so
that's the residential part but
coincidentally as an aside of course we
have been under pressure in the past to
close art and Street car park by the
County Council so that their parking
ride would be more effective so that
shows the danger of actually agreeing a
planning permission on parking
availability that may no longer be there
and I'm not saying that Arden Street car
park is that going to close because we
don't know what's going to happen from
one day to the next and that's precisely
it planning should be about doing the
best for the future for our children for
future residents of Stratford so that
there they can come here they can live
here they have got parking because we
know people rely on parking here because
they have cars we're not in a city where
you've got wonderful public transport
that is just not the situation that we
have here with regard to the
non-residential which I think was the
area that council richer's was concerned
about I have sympathy with what he's
saying and of course that the sentence
does say that the following sentence
from there to say that existing
provision will be assessed for each
individual scheme to determine whether
this is sufficient so those words may
actually cover the the inclusion of the
sentence as such existing on-street and
off-street parking is available and I
would wonder if if the officer could
confirm that that would mean that say we
had
a food retailer wanting to go into a
unit say in Regal Road whether what
their actual assessment of need would be
would be assessed against the
availability of the existing parking
thank you right well I think that's the
the point of having that sentence so on
page 51 that the sentence are such
existing on the street not street
parking is vitally it just makes it
clear to officers and applicants the
approach that the the council's is is
taking whether members think it's or it
is covered by the the following sentence
I'll leave it to you I mean it officers
Vera's it was so the inclusion that
sentence was felt appropriate as it just
gives that bit of clarity that we will
look at those those issues for for
non-residential development
detective you if I might later on at the
risk of sort of sort of I'm with
councilor Jefferson on this and I'll
explain why I think I I get what
councilor riches has said and council
organ
I think certainly within the town of
Mayberry example I think yeah common
sense prevails I think my concern is in
the town on the sort of you know areas
where you know with the rizal ready
Australian parking but there's really
you know there is car parking in the
time but outside of the town I think it
merges the argument too far in the
default position that says economics
trumps everything
and I'm not saying for one second
bearing in mind I represent award with a
high street that is struggling that
which should be ad
business in any way shape or form but we
want good business and good business
means a you know a good business that
stands a chance of working and has and
working means that customers can get to
that business and park easily and I can
point to my own ward where the high
street it there are you know pressure
already there in the sense of you know
you know people will do what they need
to do to park outside where they want to
go to it's a one stop so that means they
park at the traffic lights on the
junction over the Biddeford bridge or
they park across the Gateway of the
carpark of the flats opposite so I think
that it becomes too easy about a barrier
to about to lower bar really to get over
to say oh well we'll just consider any
parking anywhere near I think we have to
think about the economic activity the
benefit of additional economic activity
more in a more sophisticated way because
those businesses we give planning
permission for that shop or that take
away or that restaurant and if the
parking isn't right for that location it
fails already new businesses War III
fail in the first year anyway so then
you get a start to be either a rotation
of businesses on the same site or you
open up a business and then it's another
closed unit if you don't think more
thoroughly and if we don't give planning
officers the tools to think more broadly
about the economic impact and actually
making places then and achieving all of
those things within the MPP F about you
know social environmental and economic
impacts of any development then what we
end up with is it's just another
conversion and they don't matter where
people Park we've got the economic
activity but we don't get that in the
long term so I'd actually I'm actually
with councillor Jefferson on this one I
do recognize that it makes both our
policy officers and our planning
development officers job a little harder
when applications are coming forward but
it just means we have to think smarter
about this stuff and actually we forced
the developer and the owners and
operators of new units to think smarter
which means we get businesses which
thrive for the long term and we don't
get this constant churn that's where I'm
at with it
right counselor Rich's chair and yet to
clarify the counselor or Brett
absolutely nailed it as far as
residential is concerned we build an
appropriate number of car parking spaces
with it for the units that are being
built non-residential for business and
again thinking about how this discussion
is going my cabinet portfolio includes
business and enterprise I think about
the new everyman development that's just
happened in stratford-upon-avon if we
weren't allowed to take into
consideration the car parking that was
already available and forced them to
provide 300 car parking spaces for a
cinema it probably wouldn't be there and
I think in a number of businesses where
if we did that through planning policy
to force them to deliver car parking
spaces in a town that's hundreds and
hundreds of years old you know you can't
just pick up VHS and move it into a more
convenient location for the car parking
so I kinda still stand that with non
residential we have to look the planning
officers have to look at the wider
picture and the wider environment now
that doesn't necessarily mean that they
automatically assume that because
there's a car park of Bridgeville they
don't have to provide any car park
that's not what I'm saying
I'm saying is the offices should be
allowed to take a wider view on what the
general environment is with regards to
parking and vicinity for me kind of sums
that up
specifically in the context of
non-residential but if I can just spread
a little bit of light onto this we could
have a problem it's all we're all saying
let's have a new development of a new
small supermarket and then there's no
way to pass now what you're saying is if
that was a residential application we
should apply strong rules there is a
business perhaps less so but well will
it not fail if people haven't waiting by
the park because they won't come
shopping there will they but I mean you
could make a long list of businesses
that are successful in
stratford-upon-avon right now without
specific car parking spaces for their
business there's a Marks & Spencer's on
registry there's only a handful of car
parking spaces actually outside that and
are actually available it seems to be
relatively successful and there are
businesses let's not forget that might
not need a car park and cut pubs that
type of thing
you know it's not necessarily means that
everybody's gonna drive to the pub
probably shouldn't but people come to
Marks and Spencers on my bus or they
park in the wreck or the or the pleasure
center exactly or even on street exactly
and that's why I don't think we should
force the issue when it comes to parking
to say well we're not going to look at
the wider picture of it being the town
centre with numerous car parks we're
going to make you deliver car parking
spaces with any new development that
would that concerns me right I think I
mean much of council Rich's points focus
on Stratford tan and you could run an
argument that says Stratford town is a
different case I think we've got a
position or we're getting towards a
position here where you know we're
having a you know we're airing a good
debate about this and there are some
there is I think there are some valid
points on either side on and perhaps
just thinking you term some professor
gets some guidance from offices here
whether given the tone of the debate
that we we've got whether officers might
want to take this back to give some
further thought and whether we need a
view that says it's time but I don't
know I'm just thinking are we going to
get if we're not going to get to a
landing today is there something that
policy officer can think around that
helps Square some of the circle here
just floating that and perhaps looking
for John to give give some guidance or
perhaps the portfolio to give guidance
around whether this causes us other
issues you know in terms of the delay in
getting this this up on stops it's been
back and forth I'm keen that we try and
make a decision today for the simple
reason of timing we keep deferring it
eventually you know we'll just go round
in circles again no we're fully
supportive of your view I think it's
imperative to make a decision today
because we've desperately need this
parking guidance especially with regard
to residential thank you
right counsel Jefferson I would agree I
think it's important we make a decision
today but I also think that councilor
Pemberton had the right idea when it is
actually about planning officers and
policy officers actually standing back
and taking more consideration of things
in the round and I think certainly mind
you is that what we've got at the moment
is the cumulative impact of a long
period of allowing things to be built
without adequate pause that's right
and I think this now is the issue and as
long as planning officers and policy
officers could consider things in the
round but from a standpoint it says hang
on a minute we have to question whether
there is enough parking I think that's
perfectly reasonable hmm well I'm quite
prepared to take a majority decision
this afternoon counselor issues yeah I
guess so there's two things for me
because I am a I do feel a bit bit of a
rebel at the moment but I do feel that
if I if I didn't stand up then I
wouldn't be doing my cabinet portfolio
for enterprise service I think that the
enterprise shouldn't be bound by those
things but and I think you were right
counsel John I think was me actually
that suggested that planning officers
should look at things in the realm but
isn't that kind of by definition mean in
the vicinity which is why I feel that it
should probably stay for non-residential
but if John can confirm whether my my
fears are well-founded if the situation
could arise where a business tried to
redevelop let's say BHS or try and build
something new in south and all about
Stratford town centre it's across the
board
could that happen could it be that we've
we pinned them down to put a new car
parking spaces in when there are dozens
in the area that would that would
facilitate it if not then I'm happy to
go with you John I think what we do is
we say we take these words their
acceptance album cause wood Street car
park is nearly always empty
Thank You chair and just to confirm
counselors which is point yes the the
the risk of perhaps being particularly
strict with the parking standards
firstly non residential would be that
you'd then prevent new development or
change of use from coming forward
because they can't they're not policy
compliant so they can't provide
sufficient off street parking and then
that would be country to up see economic
aspirations of the council so as I said
earlier it's about that that balance I
think if I'm right what I'm hearing is
as I think a distinction between the
residential approach in the
non-residential approach so if it would
be to take out the the wording from the
page 49 but to retain it on the page 51
if that's right so let's go through the
suggestions that we've had on page 49 it
will suggest now this is residential
right and we seem to have got an idea we
want different rules or residential than
we do for non-residential so let's look
at the residential impact what we don't
want I don't think anybody's moved away
from we don't want residents occupying
district council car parking spaces even
if there's plenty of spaces like there
is in Wood Street and sound on right
because if he's like that in South I'm
it's different to my own I'll tell you
you have a job finding a car parking
space in shifts at at times so what
we're saying is in paragraph two we take
out the words and in the vicinity at the
end and in the final paragraph we take
out the words availability of parking in
the vicinity
so that's the agreed proposal right or
you're supporting that one that's all
right okay residential we're all on the
same unanimous that we take out those
two bits of wording right okay then we
move on to page 51 and the queries were
on the paragraph that starts most new
class a developments and I'm not sure
there'll be too many of these in Southam
but we suddenly have a new supermarket
in the town center and woopsie and
Gandhi bargain well that might be a
reason to refuse it and stick with
Tesco's on the edge of town however it's
easy for you to go shopping in Tesco so
where you live anyway but it is to go up
into the town centre surely he's agree
with me calm right well okay well you
can park somewhere right so okay now the
question was we were worried about
existing on-street and off-street
parking becoming available that's why
people go shopping this is not the you
know bedtime or going out for a meal in
the evening
so do we need any changes there no
well once there's no you look as if
you're gonna change that down right okay
I say I'm concerned that were there any
I I do have some concerns about given
the the widespread of businesses that
fall under Class A which go from you
know food retail or non food retail
financial services yeah so that's that's
a you know a new black branch in an ATM
through to you know pubs restaurants
takeaways I think you know you know
without sort of I think just saying oh
yeah there's parking in the vicinity
that's fine is it necessarily just the
right answer maybe it's a question of
you know we're more specific about the
classes to which that applies and I
think it is two things it's the date on
economy and the nighttime economy both
of which I have impacts on the you know
the customer can you know it's a good
parking nearby and and and particularly
excited you know the town center if you
will or the major town centers and major
rural centers if you will impacts for
residents as well so it's just John
talks about the balance and I'm just
trying to get I'm just trying to I
nudged that balance a little more in
terms of looking at the wider picture
well if we're doing that John's asked to
speak again but might I suggest and
David Baca was just whispered in my ear
this is only a comment on a policy
statement might it be a useful word to
say as such existing on-street and
off-street car parking might be
available would cheer that was that be a
compromise because we've got a divide
here that those the pointers can make
chair that I think that it's that choice
of word available it's clumsy I think
what it means is meant to be saying is
located the point they're saying is that
they're a car town in town centers there
are public car parks so we're not saying
that they're always available because
space them up in use so I just wonder if
it's changing is available to an off
street parking or located and knowing
that deal was with the issue so on that
sentence which is as such the existing
on-street and off-street parking is
available change the last two words to
say are located so it is it's a Cynthia
statement right so there's a suggestion
there which I'll pounce on it was my
suggestion that such existing on-street
and off-street picking might be
available is that agreed okay
the bit of the bottom right at the very
last paragraph again is suggesting that
we take out availability of parking in
the vicinity as is where counsel rich
doesn't agree with the rest of us
well you'll terribly worried Dave about
businesses by being forced to become
unviable but in trying to make them
viable you cause parking chaos in your
town you know I know you're not the war
member for sales I'm sorry
I think yeah we have a different view I
think that I don't think those
businesses would go there anyway I think
if they got such significant foot for
their location would determine that we
we do have to go with a majority
wouldn't be both but if there wasn't
already a car parked behind it they
wouldn't I don't think there would have
gone what you just said is my point
exactly is that they wouldn't have done
that if there wasn't a car park already
then yeah but this policy would prevent
them from doing these planning of
officers to take into account that car
park so it would have been refused
because it didn't deliver car parking
spaces in its own right right that's my
worry so you're absolutely right it
wouldn't exist if the car park wasn't
there yeah but I don't think this change
would have made that would made that
different well I'm getting the
impression that the majority wish to
remove the words available of parking
availability of parking in the vicinity
and do you want me to take a vote to
produce to prove it or yes Linda um
thank you chairman yes I would support
you and I'd like to get this finalized
so we can move on perhaps in order that
we do it with some confidence that we
asked planning to come back with a
report in six months time to see how it
has affected any potential a1 uses that
might have been adversely affected by it
because my guess is the won't be any
well there is this hypothetical big firm
that wants to sort of establish yourself
with loads of football in so anyway well
I know I wouldn't want any ships and
without parking because this is crying
but all I'm asking is the officer is
allowed to take a view on it councillor
Pemberton is absolutely right there's a
really good chance every man wouldn't
exist if it wasn't right next to a car
park
this policy prevents planning officers
from taking into consideration that car
park and it would just say if you want
to send over there you've got to put
another 200 faithful well that's my
understanding as far as the planning
policy manager is he telling me is that
the officer wouldn't be able to take a
view on the vicinity the parking in the
vicinity which would have prevented
every man from getting his planning
permission reversed but the scale of the
development itself would have driven
that right we're going round in circles
right yes John last say it just a point
that's often made I was at least the
purposes report was to endorse like an
interim guidance prior to the adoption
of the SPD so the final standards would
need to be confirmed through the SPD
itself following public consultation
half hours anyway would be over the
summer would be looking to adopt well
that just about fit Kassar organs six
months rule doesn't it beating here hot
sweltering heat of the summer debating
this again but when it goes into the SPD
so indeed so the purpose of this report
is just to get some interim guidance on
the books so the planners can have a
consistent approach to determining
applications well because there's
differences I'm gonna take a vote to one
which is it to endorse the parking
standards attached appendix worn as
amended yeah for inclusion within the
emerging draft SPT applying roundup
approach to the calculation of parking
requirements sorry what was that last
bit hold around up yeah
so you open argue with us again now ya
know chair it was just to point out that
the one of the debates we had a leaders
policy advisory group was whether we
should round to the nearest whole number
or round up the the parking spaces we
haven't had that debate it's a cabinet
and the the options presented part of
this report was to make a decision as to
whether we should round up or round to
the nearest whole number so it's just a
reminder I know we have yes I think
those two separate proposals right let's
go back to page 51 very last paragraph
availability of parking in the vicinity
so those indicate who favored that being
removed 41 we dealt with right one two
three four oh sorry I didn't spot that
right those are again so you want it
retained one two right
so that's carried then then Avengers
quietly reminded us there is the
question of round up which is on page 46
options available to endorse the parking
standards as amended for inclusion
within the emerging draft SPD applying a
rounded up approach to the e calculation
of plenary pocket regardless so we've
decided on that option proposed in
second date I know he's not voting your
one a try and persuade is not so I
expect
tariff if I may would be remiss of me if
I did not draw members of tension to the
the potential implications of applying a
more stringent approach to car parking I
understand why members might want to do
it
but whenever you try to solve one
problem with applying or creating policy
there's a risk you generate some
unintended consequences and the risk of
applying say around up approach could be
to make it very difficult for say
residents to put an extension on their
home but they should worry about that
will be the issue we're going up space
they can extend the property we're only
talking about where the calculation
result results in a figure of 9.1 to no
point four so it's only in those
instances are we really saying they've
if the calculation for parking spaces
results in 2.1 spaces 0.1 of a car that
we would require them to provide a full
third space now if that's what members
wish then so be it but I just want to
make sure members are aware of the
potential implications of doing that and
that is to prevent otherwise except
Devon from happening on a mathematical
basis and also too if development can't
go they go ahead I'm thinking of all the
the outline permissions that accompany
an hour supply pipeline if through
reserve matters we start refusing them
for the absence of parking we may
unwittingly undermine our supply now
members may think that parking issues
outweigh that that's fine that just be
be aware please of the potential
consequences of very stringent parking
when you're thinking it Oh point one to
point four for the space-time
irrespective saying that
well we had this debate al pagan yes
Linda cancer oven Thank You chairman um
there is no such thing as 0.1 of a
parking space there is no such thing as
0.4 of a parking space there is either a
parking space or there isn't and if a
house is being extended therefore giving
more bedrooms then it is reasonable to
assume that if it goes through the
threshold of requiring that number of
parking spaces if it was new build then
it should require that amount of parking
spaces if it's going to be extended I
see that as being a very logical
approach also developments that as we
know have been approved over the last
few years have been remarkably short on
parking spaces and it has created areas
where there is already not only
insufficient parking but massively
insufficient parking and to actually
make that situation worse cannot be in
the best interests of the community that
we serve right Richard no just that just
that two point one cars is is more than
two cars therefore it's three maybe you
don't get fractional cars and I think we
have to be robust we don't don't worry
about the fact that we could let them
off the one:1 and expand no and I think
simple as that I think if there are
viability issues or if there are
deliverability issues then they probably
will get dealt with it reserved matters
stage anyway I'm going to pretend we
have to be nice and they've all find
them a way of
right okay I come back to the proposal
then option one to endorse the parking
standards as modified for inclusion
applying a rounding up approach to the
calculation of parking and requirements
is that agreed no dissent right off we
go revenue and capital budget we have a
lot of pieces of paper here at which
some of us have discussed privately with
mr. Buckland including councillor Morse
who I think had his own briefing so I'm
reliably informed um oh yeah I'm adding
it well that's okay you've quite
entitled discuss it between the two of
you that's not a problem
what I'm doing is because it's now
Harper's three it is wondering just how
much debate we need on here when the
proposals are quite clear they are well
documented okay it's been produced by
the st. Buckland combination so we're
quite used to the format of the reports
and the accuracy therefore and therefore
we basically find it in the in the
recommendation it doesn't actually say
recommendation but I always says it is
recommended the following be endorsed
and recommended for scrutiny so
basically we send them off for two
things public consultation which mr.
parelle will deal with citizen panel and
the various likes and also to our own
members are wider membership for
scrutiny and they can come back to us
with other suggestions because it'll
come back to us at the next cabinet
meeting in the middle of a February when
we will make a proposal to put to
council any debate discussion
right counselor horse each other maybe I
want to debris members attention to a
couple of points I'll skate over your
previous comments to cast the Barnes
about a previous administration that
managed to freeze the council tax of six
yes no debate and let me just mention
briefly the one percent that's been
proposed here gem it seems to be a very
odd figure it seems to me to be a
compromise from the conservative group
between those who didn't want to put the
council tax up but knows that people
want the council tax up perhaps even
more to build up some even further
reserves so they didn't have to put the
council tax up next year before the
election but that's a speculation Jim
members will be aware that the reserves
are at exceptionally high level knowing
million forecast reserves revenue
reserves and nearly two million in
earmarked reserves two points I wanted
to make chairman first of all in the
medium term financial forecast the
figures were using for finance do not
correspond on tax base with the figures
that we're using for the five-year
housing supply in looking about tax base
we're saying one thing in the core
strategy five year supply
we're saying we're building at a certain
rate but we are not taking that rate of
building into account when we look at
future council tax income and I hope the
officers can perhaps give us some
guidance today as to what the gap
between those two is to quantify that
the second one chairman is that the
portfolio holder is chosen last year
three quarters of million pounds was an
earmarked reserve for interest payments
should we ever borrow money no I don't
wish to check and she accounting
treatment but it seems to me somewhat
unusual that one would not even
borrowing money yet we're putting
earmarked reserve the side
interests I have never seen that
anywhere else they're not looking at any
other costs would just say interest if
we buy money and do a developmental
whatever the interest bit of that we're
putting in earmarked reserved Islamic
the now to cover that I will thought
chairman normally were being from the
business case which would include the
interest costs all the other costs and
the impact of course of taking that to
cause immediate into the earmark Reserve
is take it out of the stated revenue
reserves to depress that figure many
residents of quite real general would
look at these figures and say why is
this councils putting the money my money
in their bank account rather than
leaving it in my bank account that's the
level to which reserves of reached
chairmen we're forecasting nine million
pounds plus the two million pounds in
not a huge sum of money for accounts for
this side right mr. Buckland himself
recommended minimum level of two million
I realize be using some of our money
chairman in future to support the future
position but I believe we've now got to
a stage where we have reserves and I
think why does this well there's two
inferences there I mean I can answer the
question of our building that reserves
I can also predicted it you know I seem
to remember the budget debates in the
council chamber last February councilor
moss made exactly the same point so
anticipating that he would be
predictably critical but he's not being
critical he's asking questions
he must sort of sit and think what would
it be like if he was in my position now
to degree I've had to discuss issues his
speculation about the divergence of
views within the conservative group is
way shorter the market right there was a
debate and a figure of one percent
was was realized because it's felt that
if you go below that then the level of
reserves will be that that is suppressed
and if the level of reserves is suppress
is not there to buffer the challenges of
the future when our funding from
national sources is going to drop
dramatically we know what that will be
which is in mine the five-year forecast
that accompanies these papers that is
clearly articulated and what you're
doing though is therefore you haven't
picked up on the fact necessarily that
we might look for a small amount of
support for economic development given
the responsibilities of this council in
that arena you've chosen to pick up on
interest now when you look around it
it's a capital expenditure Rises we will
have to pay interest there is a limit to
the amount of capital funds that we've
got they never seem to run completely
dry but on the other hand the time could
come we have as you often tell us
councillor Moore's to make some
provision for the homeless and if we
provided our own accommodation it could
be cheaper that incurs capital
expenditure and that capital expenditure
if it's from capital we ain't got it's
going to be incur borrowing and
therefore interest you know there are a
number of issues we are talking about
setting up a new housing company to look
at more affordable housing again that is
are going to require probably some
capital income now we only have one
budget here so we have to take a
estimate and when it is the budget time
we have to make the decisions that
contribute to it now so then you start
going into a complication on the
question of the changes in the tax base
well when of course strategy was adopted
July 2016 the core strategy prediction
so the tax base predictions were
probably different from what they are
now we've benefited this year as he says
in the report from the new homes -
because we built more than was actually
factored in to the calculations and the
figures that we produce 12 months ago
but at the same time these are in
determiners issues we have to guess at
what might happen and then record our
facts on what does happen so I'll never
have mr. Bachmann might like to explain
the technicalities behind your question
on the tax base thank you to explain to
explain the first one in relation to the
amount reserve so that creates in about
750,000 pound the amount reserve is
consistent with the decision that was
made by counsel back in December 2016
this provides a reserve to meet boring
costs of the cabinet making a decision
to invest up to 10 million pounds on a
strategic project without having for
reference back to council reference back
to council could slow down the
decision-making process when we're
looking to make quick decisions and the
decision of Council at that time was to
allow for this year my preserve so that
isn't a new decision as part of this
budget proposal that that was what was
put into place last year in relation to
the next base miself council Moore's
have had discussions on tax base
predictions in the past what has been
allowed within the budget being
presented today is a 1% increase in tax
base for you to the next four years
equivalent to around 550 properties
being added to that the tax base of
course the tax base isn't just
determined now by the number of new
properties which are built it's also
takes into account the number of claims
that we have through the council tax
reduction scheme we have had a reduction
in the number of working-age claimants
through the council tax reduction scheme
however if that reversed and that would
have an adverse impact on the tax base
as we move forward and finally what what
the medium-term plan doesn't allow for
either is any of increase in say the
cost of refuse collection above the
assumed increase in the tax base
therefore for every new property that we
have to take onto that
at counter Texaco surrounds its around
55 to 60 pounds in additional cost of
collection a refuge from those
departments as well it is a prudent
estimate of the tax base as we go
forward but we're going to be careful
that we don't over estimating income as
councilor st. said we know that in
twenty twenty twenty-one we're going to
have a reset on the business rates
income particularly which will have an
adverse impact on on the council's
budget reposition so American exposition
just one final comment chillin my only
concern with tax base is that we know
that developers are quite prepared and
willing to challenge over five years of
five figures I think it would be
unfortunate ourselves position to appeal
where the developer say if that is your
five year housing supply why are you not
taking that in your financial
calculation I have to interject because
that is precisely world
David Buckland has explained that the
council tax base varies according to the
number of properties there are out there
that pay council tax not the number of
properties there are out there they are
two different to budget expressed in
financial terms which is the medium term
financial plan and it is a forecast of
position it's the net position that
we're taking into account there as I
said there are other costs which are
equally not allowed for within the
medium term plan and therefore I would
argue is just a prudent financial
budgeting position and not be meant to
demonstrate that the five-year hazard
supply figure I think they're they're
two separate purposes as far as I'm
concerned
right okay any more debate on this then
car would bind to members and anybody
that may be witnessing this debate by
webcast of Appendix three parts two
because this does give a detailed
explanation as to all the changes that
we're making in the revenue budget that
we have actually increased revenue
expenditure this year Ryan which pool
utilize some of those balances
councillor Morse as I'm sure you realize
now that I shall be sitting there saying
but you've made even more money
thank you well it's glad to hear that
I'm sure you'll find something that you
don't support in us but something just
do intriguers a little bit further but
however we'll I'll put the
recommendation then on page 55 two
members of the cabinet that we endorsed
this budget and recommend it for
scrutiny and then it's over to councilor
house and the scrutiny panel's
crazy okay CEL agreed thank you right
item 12 priori Square suddenly we've
heard a fair bit about Priory square
struggling
well not to worry it's cancer carriage
coming up with you or not now will yes I
know I realize that he's put down to
speak but he were moving around the deck
chair so I just thought I'd settle first
okay we've heard a lot about Priory
square we had a case where Sarah put
away his daughter appeared at the back
of the room I was talking to Sarah about
her I've forgotten a name Holly well
Holly came here in a school uniform and
made a plea and I gave her an
undertaking that we would do something I
now discover that the same Holly's in
her first year at university yes so that
sounds a little bit of a story about the
speed at which we've been able to
progress things there's also been a
considerable amount of publicity
including that from the local enterprise
partnership and I'm gonna be a slightly
careful because I've been criticized by
the LEP so not doing my duties properly
and saying that they got things wrong
and I shouldn't do that even though I'm
leader of the council but however I
grabbed Penn's got his pencil in his
hand but the situation is that it's been
complicated by the actions of the local
enterprise partnership and we've been
still the officers are still trying to
get through to them about how their
processes are managed however what
complicated things is the coop suddenly
have taken an interest in this site when
we thought we've got an alternative plan
settled and
this has given rise to this proposal
today because whilst they own the site
we feel to a degree that were obliged to
work with them and while the some
prospect of working with them it had
been suggested that we acquire the site
somehow I love which would have required
spending some interest but the issue is
that we haven't got to that stage and we
are proposing here to mark time a little
bit with this report and we are involved
in negotiations so we will deal with
that right what I'm gonna do now is our
counselor Paul Beeman chairman of burns
the Parish Council to come up squeeze
into a spare chair thank you Paul give
us a statement of the parish's point of
view I'm sure our wall members can do it
but we'd like to hear from you as well
it's a pleasure to be here chair and an
even better to hear the ideas on
planning and parking that was a real I
also look forward to that however and
the coop and we've had the support of
counsel over there to remember and I
think the the position we are in now is
probably the strongest one we've been in
for some time to get something happening
on that sighs we had a meeting last week
with Martin Yardley and Sookie from
district council the pressure Council in
Sibley very constructive I know to that
meeting became a lot of information that
I wasn't aware of then if I'm honest
probably the ward members as well one of
the things that that was explained to us
that with the lair unless there is a
project on the ground and is actually
looking to going forwards they are
unable to put money into that fund and
so that is something that that whatever
is decided today if governor decides to
go for the composer
purchase that will automatically lead
for some project happen to come forwards
I think if that does happen the perish
canceled I get tired you have to get
their approval of it we would like to be
involved in put in any project together
that could come force to produce
something that is of benefit to the
village I don't know whether members saw
the the proposal that went round and
that was sent and I don't know whether
David's about to share that or not but
there were suggestions there that could
come forwards as something that would
benefit the whole world of village and
he could be done with relatively little
expense in the district and so as long
as co-op play the game if they are going
to come to the table and actually start
talking about serious development on the
site I think it is we are in that best
position now to where to achieve that
and but obviously me that the council
support I think having the ability to go
the compulsory purchase route if that is
the route that is deemed appropriate
will be a big enough stick to make the
coop come to the table and start
negotiating properly I that's the
question and I think Tony is is that
he's still looking into it as to what
applications have gone on on that size
and why those available we've had all
sorts of suggestions about amelioration
costs for the existence I've been too
high to make it a site that would be
worthy of developing I think those would
be worthy of investigating ensuring that
the council has that information before
it moves forwards much further on this
because if it is a site that is going to
cost hundreds of thousands to make it
into a state where it can be developed
that really puts a mocker on anything
that will be open market value and then
it has to be accounts on that scheme
with support of the coop saying well
okay we've got a site that's worth
nothing what can we do with it so that
is this is why we're saying please look
at the proposals before
or to go with the compulsory purchase if
it's something that is felt it is
appropriate
if not then usual the Paris that we
can't to get this moving because if you
say it's been a long time but nothing
happening the final one is thanks to the
decision was taken in this council
chamber with regards to planning we have
got an influx of potentially 40,000
people a year coming into Sibley and
into Stratford district at the new
castle when that is open the warning is
in development it would be not very good
for Stratford district if every time
somebody comes into the village all they
see is a boarded up site with trees and
bushes and stuff all around the edge of
it that would not be the impression that
I think Stratford district wants to
portray and I think it would give a real
impetus and a real lift to the village
if we can get this developed so just a
couple of challenge again I forgot to
tell you how to time limit well
hopefully I'm not too far over now and I
appreciate your your support in getting
that across thank you okay you've said
what you wanted to say you weren't too
far over no okay so the situation is
this question of compulsory purchase we
haven't got to that stage yet it has
been suggested by councillor courage I
know and they effectively it probably is
worthy of some consideration but the key
message today is that effectively we
keep negotiating with the coop to find
us a sustainable long-term solution
compulsory purchase is very messy and
time-consuming and if you want a
decision sooner rather than later I
think we consider that bargaining with a
current landowner is probably the most
expeditious way of dealing with that
okay
and like on one or two other issues that
we've had before us and compulsory
purchase has been mentioned we treat it
as a last resort however we know that
the powers are available to us but it's
retracted way forward
we don't necessarily
an expert in the staff amongst in that
area but we could soon find the right
the right the right issues right anybody
else wants a comment hazel because I
probably be the one person that's no no
been involved for a long long time with
it I'm I'm going back to the 23rd of
April 2012 a motion was brought before
this council which then went to the
regulatory committee on the 15th June it
was a motion put down asking to
something to be done about the coop as
with due process it went to the
committee stages and the conclusion was
we should talk to the colonel and to
know what nothing happened because he
wouldn't talk to us there in 2013 really
to representatives met with a cop and we
had an officer present and yes do you
know what they rekted some boards and
then they painted them green and why did
they do that they did it because this
council was going to take them to court
and the league in two days before so we
didn't have to appear in court Allen
again in 2014 we had meetings again with
offices and it came to council our
bishop took under the same outcome was
we should talk to the Corps in separate
2015 an amendment was put into the
corporate strategy which actually
committed the council to doing something
about it and to examine the potential
for a solution to approve the coop cited
stably this is allowed the coop to
become a priority for the council in
today's report the most long-term
solution is likely to be delivered in
conjunction with the curve that would be
very good and in theory possibly the
best way forward but I would suggest as
strongly as a key
that history suggests we are unlikely to
achieve anything but just talking to the
coop apparent steadily groups and
ourselves
I know app developers who've been
talking to them for 15 years and I can
assure you every time there's a bit of
pressure do you know what a developer's
interested I can't recall the time when
a developer wasn't going to do something
but has never come for whatever and we
could argue that that is I'm sure the
court will argue that it's an asset to
their company certainly not an asset to
struggling village or as a gateway to
our district but that money people got
blamed and there were words exchanged
but in the reality was the court
wouldn't talk to the council to be able
to make that let money useful this is
leading me to say keep to the car keep
talking to the car but I do not believe
that the only way forward is to begin is
to begin the preparation for compulsory
purchase under Section six of the
guidance issued by the Department for
Communities and Local Government this
section clearly states that land can be
acquired if it is thoroughly neglected
or unsightly in the case of this type
these words put together clearly
interrelate you can recall in the past
CPOs being done for the same reasons
around the real River Island cafe
because it was giving the same message
is that derelict in sight this isn't a
captive area I am where the compulsive
purchase can be a long protracted
process possibly taking up to five years
but ask yourself if it does take five
years
what's the coop going to doing five
years history strong suggests they'll do
nothing they'll keep typing and they'll
always have a developer that's going to
bring something forward experiences
tortoise now any announcements they've
just made about how the company is going
to go forward to the press and the media
their long-term planning regeneration
price where is not mentioned anywhere it
just isn't even on their agenda
so it's very surprised if anything
happened to this life lesson investor
keeping it secret I'm asking for this
cabinet to propose that the proposed the
thoses of compulsory purchase to be
taken forward as soon as possible
considered and brought back to cabinet I
believe that the residents would feel
more confident about they are valued by
this counselor and they're not just
somewhere stuck next to Revit thank you
so much I would like to see a real I
don't know what real principles applied
yourself Chris but we are treading water
with this recommendation and so to pick
up on
Hazel's last point all it says here is
that the potential to use compulsory
purchase powers to assist in this
objective are explored this is exactly
where we were in 2015 that's what we
asked the council to do then and that's
where we are now and I know a lots been
done in between and it's the co-op's
fault that nothing's happened as as
hazel said so I would like to the
cabinet to potentially suggest changing
the wording as the recommendation to add
at the end of that very least and
brought back the cabinet for approval in
the event account continued to fail to
deliver a solution so not just go away
and look at it we've done that for three
years let's look at it seriously and be
in a position as soon as we possibly can
to do it unless you are prepared today
to say to give permission for this
council and offices in cooperation with
Chris or whoever to actually go away and
do it from anytime today start
compulsory purchase from now or at least
bring it back to the cabinet as soon as
you can with let's start because I like
I'm very doubtful the carp are going to
play ball they have
they never do so one compulsory purchase
just for maybe some members it was
suggested that you back-to-back it right
we have a developer that our developers
interested we compulsory purchase it we
passed it straight over to a developer
for their development proposal that's
possibly the safest and easiest way of
doing it they often then pay some of the
costs which are involved in compulsory
purchase alternatively I would love to
see what what the parish hamster
proposing which is a parking and an
event space and a green social area
which will really enhance the village
and give it a focal point which is much
needed okay that's more difficult but we
can still back-to-back it with a
developer prepare to do a scheme like
that whatever happens we need to start
the compulsory purchase as soon as we
need to and we need to as soon as we can
see that yet again the co-op has failed
to do anything to more tiny points one
is that we should be pressuring the
co-op now we shouldn't just be
pressuring them with a potential
compulsory purchase we should be
attacking the fact that they've got this
on their books for half a million that's
what everybody thinks and that's why
they're not selling it that's what
they've not sold it over the last 10
years because if they sell it nobody's
going to buy it our family because it's
not worth it because if the remediation
costs we need to find out exactly what
those remediation costs are if the coop
know what they are and why they've got
it so high on their books
you know we attack their accounting if
they're counting wrong it's going to be
something wrong with that we should be
going at them for that and also
potentially using our planning
enforcement powers of section to one's
fives to force a sale after 10 years or
more it is and I thought we have a
situation down where some interesting
points have been made now councillor
Richards who is the portfolio holder is
not here today therefore is there an
officer that can
was that here Toni Sookie who's met with
a co-op but it could bring us up to date
on the position there right mr. Burke's
Thank You leader yes I did meet with the
co-op in December and they I met with
Dave Webb and one of their sort of
property leads the senior management
property there who encouraging me about
their plans for the site as they
possibly have done before it seems that
what they're planning to do is to build
a new co-op and release the sort of site
the other end of that so that the new
co-op would go on the site by the Barley
Mow and the rest of the site would be
then released for development which we
sort of fund that and they would sort of
take the co-op on the lease that seemed
to be the way things were headed they've
committed to meters again on the chart
of February following their restructure
that catch the right alluded to they'd
be publishing in sort of the media and
that meeting survives I know we'll be
going ahead when will we were expecting
to the further details from them about
what to do I can make some comments on
the compulsory purchase situation as
well if you want to see if they'd be
useful to you
I've taken some advice from Birmingham
City Council who advise us on compulsory
purchase matters and really for us to
pursue a compulsory purchase of any
likelihood of success we would need
design we would do under the planning of
poultry purchase act which necessitates
having a sort of scheme with the
planning permission in place and funding
with a view to delivering it the coop
have indicated they would resist that
but they respect our right to do it and
hence that so they pushed up their
agenda which is Riley agreed to music
skin on the top of the February we we
could pursue that another thing that we
could pursue would be just to make the
coop an offer for the site because it's
like to cost us quite a bit to go to the
cpo process you could just buy the land
but then you're faced with the problem
of having to make it work as opposed to
the coop which might be consider and
I'll pause there for
right counsel Pemberton thank you so I'm
looking at the papers I yeah we we've
got a meeting upcoming which on the face
of it seems to suggest progress what
we're being told is that there's a lack
of confidence locally a lack of
confidence locally that any of that will
come to fruition I'm not in the position
where I'm to quote the member office of
opposite ready to pull the trigger today
I am being persuaded that we need to
adopt a far more robust approach to
bring this forward and I could be
convinced in very short order in the
future
to quote pull the trigger if there isn't
that level of engagement I think
probably where I'm thinking is that
there is a discussion set for the 12th
of February which I understand is a
officers and the coop and perhaps
thinking that sort of sort of sort of
political leadership in in terms of at
least the portfolio hold our
infrastructure noting some of the
comments made and our own adoption of
this of the of transforming this site is
a priority of this cancer could
potentially be and it's very difficult
to be volunteering somebody in their
absence but if not there some other sort
of political representation that starts
to say we're taking this seriously guys
and if you're not going to bring
something forward and I think you know
running alongside that I think we have
got to have thoughts about a plan for
this site and you know if the parish
council they've got a workable a
proposal we could potentially get
perhaps
by the summertime in a position where we
could have a more rational discussion in
the app if there was the absence of
progress from the site owner around
compulsory purchase I think with when
I'm not there yet but what I do think is
that we need to find a mechanism to
actually make these guys realize we're
not going to spend another five years
tinkering around the edges of this and I
think that's probably where I'm at with
that counsel riches thanks leader so I'm
probably a lot closer to to pushing
forward to this and pulling the trigger
than you are
I'll tell you why I'll tell you why and
we made a commitment to counsel that we
had got big intentions for the studly
site and I reason I remember that is
because I had to do it because Pete was
ill he got flu and it sounds like it's
been stalled through processes that are
outside of our control and I don't like
to feel manipulated and it kind of feels
a little bit like that so I'm actually a
much more robust position than Baron I
think I think I would want to push
forward and evaluate our options on that
side now I think that doesn't prohibit
or derail the February meeting I think
if they're going to do something before
then with a developer that won't happen
anyway I'd like to establish what the
value of the site is and what our
options are really quickly although I do
feel that Pete's not here he's probably
got a strong view on it as well so I
feel a little bit ill informed because
he might have other ideas that that we
don't know about you okay well let's try
and mmm bring this to a head when you
were looking at me a bit oddly there and
I don't know what you thought I was
doing I was having a conversation with
Buckland about the timing of the next
report back to cabinet to pick up some
the points which you and others have
raised anyway the issue is that we've
got general discontent a lack of trust I
suppose the current negotiations were
change the speed of what's happened
already whereas what's happened already
as we go around in circles and then bark
it for months on end and then pick up
the baton again and go around in a few
more circles and park it again and get
nowhere I think there's a mood amongst
members for both the local members and
the cabinet members that we do need to
get on with this and it has been
suggested that compulsory purchase might
be an answer well as I said earlier it
can be an answer it's not something
we've got the expertise to handle
in-house but we have a mechanism for
dealing with issues we can't cover
in-house so I imagine that we probably
need a supplementary report sooner
rather than later I'm not sure if and
when the LEP might have a window to look
at financing and I'm not quite sure how
much money they've got available this
time last year there was a great big who
are going on because we didn't seem to
be prepared to deal with the new
sweating of growth till funding now I'm
not sure I'm getting mixed messages from
the government as to whether or not that
will happen I had expected it to happen
I haven't heard yet that it has right
and just the bottoms just muttered it
hasn't right but anyway so the issue is
shall we note the situation here and
look at where we go we clearly want a
solution right that the future of the of
the things negotiations carry on the
potential to use Scipio are explored and
as matter
oh it's never better
well I don't think we can sort of note
the recommendation we what I want to say
is we want action right yes we will look
at the logistics of compulsory purchase
which is what the recommendation
suggests we will look at whether or not
the carp are going to provide a feasible
solution but I'm also consciousness
nearly can't pass for and people to
start looking at their watch is what's
that
well Tony briefly mentioned that we
could just try and negotiate a sale of
the sight so I think there is progress
the negotiations and try and lean on
that as much as possible investigate the
practical realities of his CPA what that
like what that's likely to cost no it's
going to take and also that we start to
look at do they just want to flog the
sight and is that something that we
would want to look at as an SI I would
want to see all three of those right
when do we want those things coming back
sometime after six o'clock we good I
think when you suggested six runs he was
suggesting three yeah I was thinking
about the time we get to the beginning
of the summer we should be in a position
to actually make a final decision I
think I think I mean we've a meeting on
the 12th I do think there should be some
senior political representation at that
meeting that says guys you've run out of
runway okay we are actively
investigating how we CP over this site
or how we're going to buy this site or
how we're going to develop this site so
get your skates on the time for
prevaricate in and saying we think we've
got a developer in the wings is gone
alongside that we need to think about
how that sites going to be developed I
think we need to engage with you know
with the parish council we've got ideas
you know you know let's look at what
we're going to put on there and and
let's come back with this supplementary
report I mean we if there's a meeting
February
what's the sort of either the following
or the following on can't
from then yeah yeah the early March
cabinet you know we then we get into
considering options making the decision
which probably just take us to the
beginning of the summer to be saying
we're either gonna buy this site CPOE or
guys they've got they've got a scheme
they're going to bring forward but we
cannot go well I'm I think we're we're
just nuance between you know myself and
councilor riches you know we cannot go
into another calendar year not having a
plan for this site that's going to be
deliverable so that's yeah I think that
would be I think officers at that steer
from the from the discussion from the
local members and let's be talking about
this in them in a couple of meetings
time with with a plan a business plan
about what we're going to do with it
that we working with the cast members on
actually I'm hearing is that you wanna
further to report back into every month
we meet that that will consider all the
options and will include the resource
requirement that we would need to start
the CPA process is developing a plan
application itself and allows to design
the scheme will incur some resource
which we currently don't have a budget
for so if we include all of those kind
of issues in a report level it in two
months time I think we could meet that
deadline right so the proposal is
take on account all the points serving
raise the speed the CPI the need for an
alternative scheme to be on line etc we
take all those into account and bring a
report back to March cabinet with some
answers
and then if hazel thinks that there's a
bit of a threat to the they'll get the
message one day because that report will
be in the public domain the day it's
published what okay
is that agreed then because I'm keen to
move on it's called a basketball right
corporate strategy monitoring mid-year
councillor Thirlwall Thank You chairman
this report highlights mid-year
performance as measured against year
three corporate strategy action plan and
key service indicators for the period
April through to September 2017
inclusive look at the corporate strategy
performance where 20 tasks are due to
report this time it shows that six tasks
have been completed fibre currently on
target and nine have not been achieved
these mainly due to the long awaited
arrival in the inspector still report
and the revision of the timetable
regards planning policy issues they
should be back on target by the time we
next report back to the cabinet with
regards to key performance indicators 28
indicators have been reported with only
five not on target this be new to some
long term illness and some high demand
within services officers are working
towards achieving the targets I asked
the cabinet to note the performance
achieved in year three April to
September 2017 of the corporate strategy
2015 to 2019 thank you
well considering we now in January
September seems a long time back doesn't
we have to bear in mind that the
comments relate to life in September the
gateway site project and meetings with
one limited potential funders are
continuing with a view to securing
development funding website and we have
a target date of March this year 2018
with a comment afterwards the reason the
NA is in the status column is that we
haven't yet reached the date of March
2018 so an update status isn't it's not
applicable I will be meeting the
developer again or the peter warrick
gateway one limited I will meet him
again with a veto updating by 2018 there
are apparently two funding parties
looking at it mr. works in America at
the moment you to come back later this
month where we will have an update with
him and I'll pass that on to the cabinet
right item 14 busy to instrument Visitor
Information Center Thank You chair
so this discusses the Visitor
Information Center at Bridgeport in
January 2012 we entered a formal
agreement with Stratford college to
provide visible Visitor Information
service from the bridge bridge for
tourist information center that contract
ends on the
31st of this month following the ongoing
merger with some instructor of an ageing
Ivan college in Solihull College both
colleges have agreed not to continue
with the current arrangement of running
the visit they run the Visitor
Information Center the decision has been
made by the council or the proposal here
is that we continue the visitor
information service and we 2p the staff
into into the district and continue to
deliver the service until we can a later
data to consider it there any comment so
effectively we undercover the service
within budget from the beginning of
February whilst longer-term solution is
sorted out whether or not that involves
the college remains to be seen because
at the moment they're going through
their change so d wounding all the
college okay so are we happy with the
recommendation on page 155 that's the
great finding item 15 capital budget
monitoring council and thank you
chairman this is the capital budget for
the first eight months of the year and
the total planned expenditure for the
year ending March 2018 is four million
three hundred and six thousand and
progress of the projects is detailed in
the tables on appendix one and appendix
2 which is on page 167 gives details of
the uncommitted section 106 payments
which are held by the council along with
their spend by dates where applicable
thank you
any questions
Celinda queries
no there's not much of an update needed
there so the position on capital
expenditure per p1 toy is received tell
agreed we're not identifying any issues
for further consideration right we then
move on to the revenue budget which is
item 16 Thank You Carolyn thank you
again this applies to the same period
the first statements of the financial
year which ends in March 2018 it shows a
very favorable variance for the period
of 170,000 along with a favorable out to
turn forecast of two hundred and eighty
three thousand nine hundred and
ninety-six the significant reasons for
the variance is detailed in paragraph
five of the report which is on page 173
and this is also illustrated within the
first two appendices thank you now
effectively was counselor Morsi yeah
now this this favorable variance on
outturn he's not as great as we've had
in recent years so this is why we've
sometimes had these reserves bumping up
but I think in the next couple of years
we'll be glad of those reserves at the
level which they are okay lot of figures
here which explain where we are
unfavorable and unfavorable variances
not too many unfavorables are we happy
with those so the variance of period 8
and the estimated revenue out sir and is
received
. there's no issues identified
further consideration request for white
ops approved and also another rights off
in paragraph to point forms is that will
agree yeah I think that's more or less
it
we need the forward plan we should have
been circulated separately okay which is
giving us a fair bit of word to do next
month that's item 17 urgent business
madam chairman right well in that case I
can declare the meeting closed so we can
disperse